so well you jumped into shawshank
because of the prison thing but
i was just i rewatched it because i had
to because it's been a couple years and
it's one of the best movies ever made
period i mean is that something that
they offered you or did you had to
read for that oh i read for it yeah yeah
i read for it was one of the worst
auditions i ever had
um with
frank and the casting director and um
casting director was a
young lady and she was dressed in a nice
really floral blouse and she smelled
good and she was done up and
and i had to scream at her
uh you know you'll [ __ ] when i say you
[ __ ] and you'll piss when i say you piss
you got that you mega dick mother i
i couldn't do it i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it i i couldn't get it out
and i apologized
to frank at the end of it i said i'm i'm
sorry i did you you smell too good i
can't
i can't get this out
you know i can't yell at you this way
you're you're a nice young lady i can't
i just
i couldn't do it so i left there
thinking i'm never gonna be in this
movie
it's too bad it's such a good script and
i'll never be
so what happened so they called up and
they offered it to me they said yes now
you'll be alright you'll be good
i mean and on the flight out i mean i
was convinced
they had made a mistake they thought i
was somebody else and
i you know they shot it in mansfield
ohio so we're flying into
columbus or wherever we're flying into
which is it which is a flight i've taken
before
because that's where i'm from and i'm
sitting there
and back in the day when they flew you
first class i'm sitting there in first
class and i see all these actors roll in
you know all these really good actors
dave pro ball
and joe ranyo and and
you know just everybody that is there
gutting and
and uh and they see uh
i see uh bill sadler
and i'm like oh damn
that's that's who they think i am they
think i'm bill sadler and he's going to
be playing my role
and so i just realized the whole flight
i was just like
in the window seat it's like this is
going to be so embarrassing when i get
there and they tell me
that they're going to send me home i was
absolutely convinced
hang on you're on this whole three four
five hour flight you swear to god this
is what you're thinking
you're thinking they're not they got the
wrong guy yeah oh yeah i mean not until
we sat down and we
read that we had a read through i was
convinced
i mean you know they had mark ralston
and
sadler and i i mean they had like all
these great actors
brian libby and and i mean you know
i'm trying to come up with everybody's
name
they're all guys that i recognize and
they're all character actors and they're
all terrific and i'm sitting there going
i'm not gonna this is not who they think
i'm somebody else
are you intimidated i wouldn't say i was
intimidated i knew i gave a bad
audition
i've had those the worst case scenarios
people always say i want offers i like
offers
but when you get an offer and then you
go in and then they're like
no that's not what we want but if you
audition for something and they like
what you did
then you do that most the time right so
you go in there and you do something
that you're like well [ __ ] i barely even
got anything out i don't even know why
i'm here
yeah and then and then you get there and
then like what's what's your first day
like what's your first day as an actor
going i shouldn't even be here
no it was we went up for a rehearsal
back in the back that's back when they
were harshly rehearsed right so we so
we sat down and we had a read through
and there's morgan and tim and
you know all the guys and gotten and
whatnot
and we have the read through and it says
you know on your little thing it says
clancy brown
captain hadley so that's like when the
first time i thought
okay they that's
when i sit down they'll realize that
they think
somebody else is clancy brown you know i
mean
yeah not until it's not until i we
started reading it and
nobody seemed to blink an eye and i you
know mean it was the most intense
imposter syndrome i've ever had was that
jesus and then and then once we started
going it was fine you know it was okay i
mean i watched that scene on the rooftop
like it's you're so intense that even
years later i've seen this movie
everyone's seen it and then you watch it
again i really think you're gonna throw
tim robbins off the roof
i really feel like you're losing your
[ __ ] but it's
it's this contained [ __ ] just pure
innate disdain for this man or any of
these people around you
and i'm like it's such a powerful
character
and you're thinking there oh my god
prison's really
hard i bet they were like this and
prison sucks god i mean
he's stupid he's a stupid stupid man
he's just such a dumb man
it's like that's those are the people
that you're afraid of most
oh yeah authority that are so deeply
ignorant
that they do stuff like throwing people
off roofs
what is wrong with that guy isn't that
the truth though well there are people
like that
around us that are just you're like wow
they just don't see what we've seen
and and you hate to think well what i
say is right but then you're saying well
this is this is just the right way
though am i missing something here
how does this guy think the opposite of
what i think so far
but you know that's that's the way it is